Speaker 1: Remember that The David Pakman
Show quite literally depends on your support,
primarily through the membership program which
you can sign up for.
Join Pacman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members
and I would love to see you in the audience
of that world famous bonus show sign up at
join Packman dot com.
I want to talk to you today about the continued
scandal surrounding lying Republican Congressman
George Santos and what is now it's not even
really an alleged past as a drag queen.
And I know that the term queen, is it appropriate,
is it not?
I don't really know.
Now, before I dive into the topic, I want
to start with, I don't care about drag queens
in the sense that I don't believe drag queens
are a danger to children.
I don't believe drag queens are a prominent
or important political, social, cultural or
economic issue to be describing or talking
about.
I just to me, drag queens are a non-issue.
Republicans have made drag queens an issue,
claiming some of the things I just said I
don't believe, claiming as Republicans have,
that putting together children and drag queens
is dangerous to children in some way working
to get drag queens story hours of different
kinds where men dressed in drag read stories
to kids.
They have made it a political issue and have
claimed that there is a fundamental immorality
to drag queens.
And now it turns out that lying Republican
Congressman George Santos regularly dressed
in drag.
Now, I don't know if there is a pejorative
connotation to saying drag queen.
I don't know if there is a difference between
dressing in drag regularly and being a, quote,
drag queen.
I don't know the difference, but it seems
to me that George Santos was a drag queen
for a period of time.
Businessinsider now reports George Santos
party in drag over a three year period, New
videos appear to show, despite a suggestion
it was a one off.
I want you to remember he initially said it's
not him in the pictures when these pictures
came out of Santos reportedly dressed in drag.
It's not me.
More recently, he said it's me.
I did it once.
I had fun, so sue me.
But now, videos and photos spanning a three
year period, 2005 to 2008 appear to show Santos
in a drag persona.
He went by the name Katara.
So we are now we've got Jorge Santos.
We have Anthony devoted there.
Now we have Katara, which was his drag character,
George Anthony Katara.
Santos divulged there.
They have been fear mongering against the
LGBT community.
They have been fear mongering about drag queens.
And now it turns out that one of their own,
who they are very hesitant to just condemn
and say, this guy is such a liar, he should
resign.
He just he should resign.
Members of Congress have not been doing that
in any significant numbers.
They now are saying nothing about it.
And the story first broke last week when freelance
journalist Marissa Cuevas published a substack
post about the drag queen past of Jorge Santos.
And it included the pictures and testimony
of friends and all of it.
And even in the follow up of this story, George
Santos continued to lie first, saying it wasn't
him, then saying he did it once and then now
we have evidence that he was regularly dressing
in drag.
I don't care that George Santos dressed in
drag.
I don't care.
What I care about is he lies about everything.
Everything.
And, of course, the selective outrage from
Republicans about if and when he's doing the
right thing or the wrong thing versus when
it's Democrats is disappointing.
It's disgusting and it's pathetic.
So, yeah, I'm disappointed that there are
more lies.
But it's also important to call out their
hypocrisy.
And I still am increasingly convinced that
Santos is going to be able to just stick this
out and eventually the media is going to move
on.
But the stories continue coming, and I've
got to talk about a crazy one next.